and how about right back to biden
there's a new leaked tape from hunter
biden
where he was caught talk acts ostensibly
from hunter biden
talking about how deeply mired in
corruption particularly in china
the biden family was i get calls from my
father
to tell me that the new york times is
calling but my old partner eric who
literally has done me
harm for i don't know how long is the
one taking the calls because my father
will not
stop sending the calls to eric i have
another new york times reporter calling
about my representation of the
literally dr patricko the
[ __ ] spy chief of china
we started the company that my partner
who was worth
323 billion dollars found it
it is now missing the richest man in the
world is
missing who was my partner he was
missing since i last saw him in his 58
million dollar apartment and signed a
four billion dollar deal
to build the largest lng court
in the world
i am receiving calls from the southern
district of new york
from the us attorney himself my best
friend in business
devon has named me as a witness without
telling me
in a criminal case and my father without
telling me
so this goes on i i misspoke earlier i
said that it shows the kind of deep
corruption
that the biden family was mired in it's
not was it is
it is mired in this corruption right now
and it appears to go all the way to the
top
that's country over party is that what
that is i don't think so that's the
country
that's the country over party that's
where we're going to rename the
democrats the country over party
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you